hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tochter hält viele von euch haben sich
von mir eine schöne halloween torte
gewünscht und ich habe mir etwas ganz
besonderes einfallen lassen heute gibt
es nämlich eine 3d halloween kürbis
torte und die sieht jetzt so aus und ihr
denkt jetzt wahrscheinlich oh mein gott
das kriege ich ja niemals hin aber die
torte ich wirklich nicht schwer
herzustellen und ihr braucht nicht mehr
lange zeit dafür das geht alles relativ
schnell sage ich dann am ende des videos
wie lange ich in etwa gebraucht habe und
ich werde jetzt hier einen leckeren
kürbis tag zu bereiten
aber wenn euch das zu aufwendig ist weil
man da eben kürbispüree machen muss dann
könnt ihr auch ganz einfach euren
lieblings teilnehmen
ich werde euch auch noch einen
alternativ teilt auf meinem blog
schreiben und ich will jetzt einfach mal
sagen ich starte direkt mit dem video
alles was ich hier verwende also auch
mein werkzeug meine zutaten werde ich
euch alles unten in meiner infobox
verlinken da wo info steht da könnte
alles anklicken
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß beim zuschauen und bin schon
gespannt wie ihr die torte findet ich
habe hier acht eier 400 gramm zucker 260
gramm kakaopulver 320 gramm nüsse die
habe ich jetzt bereits gemalt
440 gramm mehl 600 gramm kürbis püree
das habe ich bereits auf gekochtes waren
hokkaido kürbis ursprünglich und es ist
jetzt bereits abgekühlt
zwei kirchen backpulver zwei esslöffel
zimt und eine gute prise salz und ich
nehme dann noch zum würzen etwas
muskatnuss die muss natürlich nicht sein
aber gibt im ganzen schönen geschmack
und esse jetzt die zutaten für meine
drei backformen ich habe jetzt nämlich
hier bereits drei backformen vorbereitet
und zwar ist es eine springform mit 28
cm durchmesser eine mit 24 21 und ich
hab die springform isoliert damit meint
eick schön gleichmäßig hoch wie das geht
weil ich in meinem bauch toppen video
das verlinken
einfach und hier könnt ihr natürlich
auch rahmen benutzen die möglich auch
immer ganz gerne aber ich habe zeit für
die spring formen entschieden
zuerst hätten jetzt die eier mit dem
zucker richtig schön schaumig gerührt
dann kommen die nüsse das öl und die
trockenen zutaten mit rein und dann wird
einfach alles zu einem glatten teig
verrührt und zum schluss gebe ich noch
das kürbis muss mit dazu und dann
einfach nur noch ganz kurz unterrühren
und dann wird der teig auf die drei
förmchen aufgeteilt ich gebe jetzt den
größten teil in die große form und teilt
dann den rest auf und dieses rezept habe
ich insgesamt zwei mal gemacht und habe
noch mal in jeder form gebacken
so dürfen die teige jetzt bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze gebacken werden
die backzeit richtet sich dann einfach
nach den förmchen und ihr müsst einfach
die stäbchen probe machen
danach ließ sich den kuchen aus der form
und lasst ihn am besten über nacht
auskühlen
hier habe ich jetzt eine kupferplatte
bereits zugeschnitten das sind 20 cm
durchmesser
da kommt etwas gras drauf und da lege
ich jetzt meine mittleren tortenboden
drauf streiche da etwas mobile hat auch
drüber und legt dann die zweite großen
tortenböden drüber und so besitzt der
kuchen gestapelt
der kuchen wird dann erstmal gekühlt
danach stelle ich ihnen auf eine
tortenplatte auf eine drehbare und hab
dann blecht runter damit da gleich die
kuchen krümmel rein fallen können
und jetzt wird der kuchen mit einem
messer zu recht geschnitzt einfach von
oben nach unten anfangen und den kuchen
erst mal eine runde bzw ovale form
schneiden
der kuchen soll jetzt nicht ganz rund
sein sondern eher etwas obama bei seinem
kürbis wird oben schneide ich dann noch
einen kleinen öffnung ein
und markiere mit an außen die linien die
dann später den kürbis formen soll
die schneide ich mir dann etwa 15 cm
tief ein sodass sich das später schön
aus formen kann
die striche sollen jetzt von oben bis
unten führen nur ein strich führt bei
mir nur bis zur mitte weil da dann noch
gleich das gesicht drauf kommt
anschließend nehme ich mir etwas
takanashi das rezept findet ihr auf
meinem blog und streich jetzt erstmal
eine schicht komplett um den kuchen
herum und stellt den kuchen dann für
etwa zehn minuten kühl
so werden jetzt erst mal die krümel
gebunden aus dem kuchen resten könnt ihr
übrigens cake pops herrschten deswegen
sammle ich die einfach ein und verweist
sie dann etwas weiter
dann kommt jetzt eine zweite schicht
kanals auf den kuchen drauf und die
solltet ihr so glatt wie möglich darauf
streichen das geht am besten mit einer
winkel palette
für die feinheiten nehme ich jetzt meine
mini mini palette und kann hier schön
die ecken und kanten aus formen und die
einzelteile glatt streichen
oben soll das kleine loch bestehen
bleiben
aber dieses muss natürlich auch schön
ausgeformt werden und dann wenn der
kuchen dann komplett eingestrichen ist
wird er einfach kühl gestellt
anschließend nehme ich mir meine brille
werkzeug da könnte aber auch ein
zahnstocher nehmen und hier muss ich mir
jetzt erst mal mein gesicht für den
kürbis vorzeichnen oben die augenbrauen
die augen aus sparen und einen mund der
etwas böse sein soll hier benutze ich
jetzt etwas marzipan und kann das
einfach auf die gage aufdrücken und mit
meinen fingern etwas formen
die augenbrauen werde ich aus einem
stück vorne und die übergänge werde ich
dann mit etwas ganache verstreichen
damit sie einen sehr weichen übergang
zur schokolade habe
während der kuchen jetzt kühlt werde ich
schon mal meinen rolf unternehmen und
zwar habe ich den jetzt in der
praktischen ein kilo verpackung im eimer
und da habe ich den vorteil dass es so
denn von dort nach dem gebrauch einfach
wieder verpacken kann und verstauen kann
ich werde jetzt für die torte insgesamt
15 kilo von hand nehmen und werde diesen
dann mit meinen passenden farben in gelb
und rot einfärben
zuerst muss aber davon dort mit etwas
palmen an den händen weiß geknetet
werden
und da ist es am besten ihr reißt euch
kleine stücke ab und knetet sie dann
nach und nach wracks treten damit ich
träume fahre vorbereiten kann
ich nenne jetzt wieder hier die pasten
farben von deco pack und werdet gelb und
rot benutzen damit ich es einfach den
von dort aus
da gibt jetzt einfach so viel rein bis
ein schönes orange und stimmt
ein kuchen ist jetzt schön kalt und
bevor ich ihnen jetzt mit verdammt
überziehe muss ich jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz mit einer dünnen schicht zb von
diesem termin einfetten damit einfach
kuchen jetzt nicht so trocken ist denn
wenn ich jetzt auf den trockenen kuchen
auf diese trockene ganache den vom land
lege dann kann es passiert die luft
blasen mit einarbeiten und das will ich
ja nicht weil es nicht schön aussieht
und deswegen muss ich denn einfach nur
ganz kurz befeuchten
jetzt nehme ich hier diese schreckliche
platze weil ich nicht möchte dass man
von dort leicht reduziert und arbeite
immer auf so einer sauberen platte und
das ist übrigens weder dieser
drehtellern den ich mal von ihrer
gewohnheit anschließend nehme ich meinen
vom band rollen auf etwas egger stärke
aus am besten mit einem großen auswahl
starb und da müsst ihr ihn immer wieder
drehen damit er schön gleichmäßig wird
ich rolle ihnen jetzt etwa 5 mm dick aus
und nicht dünner weil ich ihn später
noch etwas einritzen möchte und mit ihm
arbeiten muss auf den ausrutscher ohne
drücken
und dann kann ich den trüber ausfallen
und dann streicht ihr mit euren händen
den von dann von oben nach unten glatt
und sie den immer wieder zur seite und
streicht den bis nach unten
die über stände werden dann einfach
weggeschnitten
hier möchte ich jetzt absichtlich eine
falte ein baum einfach damit der kürbis
gleich etwas verschrumpelt aussieht die
überreste werden dann einfach
weggeschnitten
das geht am besten mit einem marzipan
messer
und jetzt einfach den kompletten kürbis
erst mal ab das geht ganz gut mit einem
trockenen pinsel und die sich auch der
vorteil von becker stärke dass es
einfach danach wieder wechselt jetzt
müsst ihr mit euren fingern hier die
konturen richtig schön nachfahren dann
die gesichtszüge session erkennen kann
und jetzt nehmt euch irgendwas
scharfkantiges und ritzt hier jetzt noch
kleine falten ein
und jetzt nehme ich mir etwas farbe in
schwarz braun und rot die habe ich auch
bei mir im kopf ich werde euch einfach
alles unten in der infobox und nehme
jetzt einfach einen trockenen pinsel und
werde jetzt hier noch schattierungen
setzen die studieren müssen natürlich
immer an die tiefsten ecken damit
einfach diese noch dunkler und tiefer
aussehen und der kürbis realistischer
wirkt
minister wattiert habt ich habe jetzt
auch komplett hier über die rillen
drüber dass die einfach mehr tiefe
bekommen dann nehme ich mir noch mal
etwas von diesem von dort und werde
damit ein paar warzen modellieren
und dann müssen die einfach drum herum
noch etwas schockiert werden
aus weißer modelliermasse oder blüten
passte werde ich jetzt noch die zähne
herstellen
und jetzt nehme ich mir wieder weiße
blüten passte oder modelliermasse und
form damit die augen und dann muss das
ganze auch noch etwas schockiert werden
und dann nehme ich mir etwas pulver
farbe ich habs jetzt mit etwas alkohol
angemischt damit sie eben zum malen
benutzen kann
ihr könnt aber auch ganz gut
lebensmittel farbstifte nehmen zb die
von deco back und könnte damit dann die
augen auf malen mit schwarz malige
zielgerade die pupille auf und dann
möchte ich mir noch ein rot an und male
damit etwas blut an die zähne und
daneben auch noch an dem auge weiter
mit einem feinen pinsel könnt ihr dann
noch kleine äderchen dran mal
und dann noch die kontur für das auge
ziehen ich habe jetzt hier an der stelle
vergessen noch einen weißen punkt auf
das auge zu setzen
das sollte man auf jeden fall auch
machen damit die augen etwas dollar
erscheinen und für den stängel da oben
rein habe ich mir jetzt etwas marzipan
genommen habe etwas im sparschwein
gegeben damit eben etwas geschmack
bekommt und dann ein bisschen schwarz
und grün eben auch von diesen tasten
farben also hier auch dieses autofreie
schlag und die zeit hier oben den
stängel formen
jetzt freue ich mich einfach aus den
resten noch so ein paar lange stränge
ich hatte meine böden bereits einen tag
vorher gebacken und am nächsten tag habe
ich dann ungefähr für die fertigstellung
und zusammensetzung der torte so
ungefähr fünf stunden gebraucht also im
prinzip diese torte wirklich sehr
schnell gemacht und jetzt sind wir schon
in den endzügen und ich werde sie
einfach komplett restaurieren
ich habe jetzt hier ein kate bush und
zwar gibt es die jetzt auch in schwarz
oder sie spielt in meiner lieblingsfarbe
in pink es gibt aber auch hellblau und
silber und die gibt es jetzt auch
neuerdings bei uns im shop
ich finde die einfach so schön weil man
die dann nicht mehr übersehen muss also
ich bin schwarz passt sowieso immer als
kontrast zum beispiel und hier natürlich
sowieso super ich wette die da hinten
drauf setzen
später rauskommen
ich würde sagen dass ich mir du wenn du
morgens aufsteht und jetzt könnt ihr
hier einfach noch ein paar accessoires
brauch setzten
ich habe zum beispiel dieser total
widerlichen spinnen gekauft mittlerweile
habe ich mich daran gewöhnen kann sie
anfassen ich konnte echt nicht anfassen
am anfang nicht so eklig oder ich mag
keine spinnerte euro also ich habe jetzt
keine spieler modelliert ist können wir
natürlich auch machen aus blüten passte
aber die wird mir sowieso nicht mit
essen weil meistens die deko aus blüten
passt ihr nicht gegessen wird weil sie
zu hart wird und deswegen habe ich jetzt
einfach mal eine plastik spiele genommen
weil sie einfach danach wieder weiter
verwaltet werden kann
die sammler spielt ganz gern damit und
schmeißt du mir mal so und habe ich noch
ein paar mini spinnen die kann man hier
einfach gut drauf setzen und schon sieht
die torte etwas gruselig aus samira hat
gestern auch die ganze zeit gesagt mama
die taten sieht großartig aus
und so ist dann die torte fertig
gestaltet ich finde es wirklich
erstaunlich wie schnell und so eine
torte gestalten kann
vor allen dingen weil es mit 3d torte
ist und das feld trottete wird er locker
für 30 leute denke ich mal reichen weil
jeder nur ein kleines stück ist und
dieses rezept gibt dann natürlich ab
morgen zum nachlesen auf sallys -
blog.de ihr könnt wie gesagt diesen tag
machen oder auch gern ebenen anderen
teig das ist ja komplett egal ich freue
mich auf jeden fall über eure kommentare
und euer feedback wie euch diese torte
gefallen hat und vielleicht macht sie
auch der ein oder andere nach
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken und wünsche euch noch einen
ganz ganz schönen tag des bades
die trainer müssen die zähne